il ya quelques mois le président
français emmanuel macron a monté une
commission chargée de faire des
propositions dans le champ de
l'éducation de la régulation et de la
lutte contre les diffuseurs de haine et
de la désinformation et oui je viens de
site wikipédia parce que je voulais
vraiment pas dire de bêtises cette
commission est présidée par le
sociologue gérald brunner et il ya
quelques semaines gérald brunner m'a
demandé de répondre à des questions dans
le cadre de cette commission est alors
sachant les critiques de cette
commission et sachant à quel point le
dénigrement par association est fréquent
dans la sphère publique je dois dire que
je n'étais pas ultra chaud pour
participer je n'ai absolument pas envie
qu'un journal se met à écrire un article
avec les mots macron paix que nous et
aux angles dans le même titre d'autant
que du dénigrement par association je l'
ai déjà vécu il ya quelques mois après
avoir collaboré avec le ministère de la
santé qui a conduit à une vidéo qui a
plus de dix lacs que de like refaite et
la perte de confiance en un scientifique
suite à une collaboration avec des
institutions envers lesquels il ya
beaucoup de défiance est un phénomène
documenté est avérée par une étude
récente d'un autre côté quand je vois ce
que le ministère de la santé a produit
sans le consulter notamment au sujet des
hospitalisés vacciner je me dis qu'il
serait en fait très dangereux que les
scientifiques refusent d'être consultés
par des commissions des institutions
publiques et bon j'ai envie dire que le
problème avant tout c'est un problème de
manque de séparation des expertises en
particulier le fait que le gouvernement
ait autant d' influence sur des
décisions ou l'expertisé scientifique
est beaucoup plus importantes comme la
gestion de la pandémie la transition
énergétique ou la régulation des
algorithmes mais bon c'est un autre
sujet bref j'ai fini par accepter d'être
consultés mais à condition de pouvoir
être transparent dans la manière dont
j'ai été consulté l' influence de ma
consultation est ce que j'ai dit dans la
consultation après tout il me semble
qu'il n'y a aucune raison que tout ceci
reste secret et au contraire mes
réponses aux cinq questions que gérald
bronner m'a posé pourrait peut-être vous
intéresser et du coup je vais vous
donner ces réponses et c'est parti
[Musique]
quel est d'après vous les cinq
références les plus couvrante et
récentes sur cette question de flux
d'information chambre d'écho
polarisation et c'est impossible de
faire le tour des références pertinentes
mais du coup j'ai recommandé cinq
bouquins qui me semblent
particulièrement complet pour comprendre
la manière dont l'information est
aujourd'hui produite des fusées
consommer et les conséquences de cela
sur la société le premier livre est 8h à
une tear gas de ces nappes tout fait
cheap tout fait qui est un peu devenu
une superstar pendant la crise du que
vides grâce à ses nombreuses positions
qui se sont avérés très perspicace a
posteriori et son merveilleux
raisonnement probabiliste tout au long
de la pandémie m'étouffer pied avant
cela et aujourd'hui encore et surtout
connu pour ses travaux en sociologie du
numérique et des mouvements politiques
initiées ou amplifié par les réseaux
sociaux avec toujours un tableau plein
de nuances melandez réussite formidable
et des catastrophes gravissime du
printemps arabe à des émeutes violentes
comme les émeutes du capitole même si
bon de livres date de 2017 du coup il ne
parle pas du capitole mais on sent qu'il
anticipe le deuxième livre que j'ai
recommandé l ue walter reed de jolis
jackson j'en avais déjà parlé dans une
vidéo cndd ce forum je suis ravi de
recommander ce livre à nouveau dans ce
livre joe jackson parle du bief de
négativité dans les médias et les
conséquences très néfastes que ceux ci a
sur notre représentation du monde sur
notre santé mentale et sur votre volonté
à agir si on veut améliorer le monde
selon elle il est crucial de corriger ce
biais de négativité et faire du
journalisme en particulier des solutions
qui consiste a aussi parlé de solutions
potentielles sans jamais bien sûr les
survendre malheureusement de nos jours
un tel journaliste est souvent moins
rentables se fait moins de vue et du
coup sans mesures additionnelles comme
des subventions par exemple il ya peu de
chances que ce journalisme conquiert le
paysage médiatique troisième livre que
j'ai recommandé est de reality game the
same way rouler c'est un livre qui parle
très bien de l'ampleur de la
désinformation que beaucoup de gens ne
semble gravement sous-estimé pour donner
quelques chiffres sur facebook 6
milliards de faux comptes sont retirés
par an et en chine 20 millions de
chinois sont payés produire de la
désinformation de mon expérience la
plupart des gens sous-estiment ces
chiffres d'un facteur 100 mille voire
dix mille ce qui signifie qu'on sous
estime probablement l'ampleur de la
désinformation d'un tel facteur aussi de
plus le livre parle bien de différentes
formes que peut prendre la
désinformation il ne s'agit absolument
un pack de fait qui nous en fait la
plupart de la désinformation semble
plutôt chercher à détourner l'attention
du public ou à harceler les producteurs
de contenus compromettant avec des
menaces de mort ou parfois avec thé
lipton le quatrième livre que j'ai
recommandé est vrai que machines de
sinan aral sinan aral est un professeur
du meti qui a basé sa carrière à étudier
les dynamiques sur les réseaux sociaux
allant de phénomènes de chambre d'écho à
la diffusion massive de fausses
informations dans ce livre aral
synthétise ainsi des décennies d'études
scientifiques du domaine de plus a
raconté position inhabituelle mais qui
me semble très bien justifiée sur par
exemple la décentralisation du web et
sur la protection des données
personnelles enfin le cinquième et
dernier livre qui est un peu de l'auto
promotion c'est le livre le fabuleux
chantier que j'ai coécrit avec el mahdi
el mhamdi aujourd'hui professeur à
l'école polytechnique en france et
chercheur à google brain le livre a été
écrit en 2019 et s'il ya plusieurs
aspects de ce livre avec lequel je ne
suis plus tout à fait entièrement
d'accord l'essentiel de ce livre me
semble étonnamment encore plus
perspicaces vu d'aujourd'hui qu'au
moment où ce livre a été écrit il ya
deux ans avant la crise du coc vide en
particulier le livre introduit toutes
sortes de briques qui aujourd'hui sont
en train d'être empilés construire le
projet tournesol qui est vraiment en
fait l'aboutissement des réflexions du
livre il y aurait tellement d'autres
livres qui ont failli faire partie de
cette liste mais bon cinq livres ça fait
déjà beaucoup de lecture sinon pour tout
vous dire je me suis aussi permis de
recommander la série de vidéos que je
réalise en ce moment sur l'éthique des
algorithmes
[Musique]
toujours à ce sujet quels sont les
connaissances qui d'après vous sont les
plus solidement établie dans la
littérature de très nombreux
gouvernements et entreprises à travers
le monde dépense au monde des millions
de dollars dans des campagnes de
désinformation je répète et des chiffres
que j'ai déjà mentionné facebook retire
6 milliards de faux comptes par an
tandis que la chine emploie 20 millions
de désinformateurs à côté de ça la
vulgarisation des sujets scientifiques
importants et porté par une petite
centaine d'individus avec des budgets
souvent très limité le combat de
l'information aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
une bataille de david contre goliath
et contrairement à ce qui se passe dans
la bible goliat est en train d'écraser
david une autre chose très avéré et le
fait que notamment en 2016 aux us la
russie a produit énormément de
désinformation surtout dans le but de
semer un chaos social et pas à temps
pour défendre une idée précise j'en
profite pour passer à de la spéculation
qui nous paraît hautement probable il me
semble très probable que la russie mais
aussi d'autres comme par exemple la
chine participe activement au chaos
informationnel du coc vide dans les
démocraties et oui imaginez vous
dirigeant d'un pays autoritaires l'une
des plus grandes menaces pour vous ça
serait que le peuple exige plus de
démocratie et donc vous avez tout
intérêt à produire des contenus ultra
polarisant dans les démocraties pour
diviser ses populations et ensuite dire
à votre peuple ba a regardé la
démocratie ça marche pas une autre chose
avérée surtout maintenant avec les
facebook files se finira certainement
par faire une vidéo sur ce sujet ô
combien important c'est que les
algorithmes de recommandation ont un
impact majeur sur le chaos
informationnel en maximisant la tension
il favorise les contenus
sensationnaliste et clivant et si vous
en doutez je vous invite vivement à
écouter ce podcast qui s'appuie sur des
communications internes à facebook et
révèle le fait que de nombreux employés
de facebook ont fait toutes sortes d'
analyse qui le confirme très largement
une autre chose qui semble bien établie
c'est le fait que le problème des mythes
news à savoir les informations noyé dans
un océan d'informations moins importante
c'est un problème aussi dangereux que le
problème défectueuse d'ailleurs la
désinformation chinoise semble beaucoup
plus s'appuyer sur les mutins news que
sur les technos pour taire les critiques
du gouvernement enfin une autre chose
bien établie c'est que la désinformation
abuse beaucoup de cyber harcèlement
notamment à l'encontre des journalistes
d'ailleurs j'ai participé récemment à la
conférence publique pour le castor
internacional 2021 à bruxelles dont l'un
des événements phares était la
publication d'une déclaration de
bruxelles qui appelle les réseaux
sociaux a beaucoup plus protéger les
journalistes du cyber harcèlement dont
ils sont victimes quand leurs
investigations nuisent à des entités
puissante
[Musique]
eux-mêmes quels sont les points qui font
encore débat
l'un des grands sujets de débats et
l'importance des algorithmes de
recommandation dans la mésinformation
dans la population générale clairement
ces algorithmes ont un impact mais
clairement aussi la mésinformation sur
ces news ou dans les bouquins en de la
fnac ont aussi un impact majeur est
clairement aussi les baies cognitives de
la population générale sont un facteur
important dans la popularité de
certaines des informations il ya
certainement du travail à faire sur tous
ces fronts à la fois et des besoins de
financement pour lutter contre chacune
de ces sources de mes informations ceci
dit changer les algorithmes de
recommandations me paraît aujourd'hui
plus simple que changer la programmation
des médias classiques ou les
vulnérabilité psychologique des
consommateurs surtout sachant les
révélations des facebook rise il ya
aussi des grands débats autour d'un
pacte delà des plates formes isation des
grandes sources de désinformation sur
l'ampleur de la désinformation plus tard
d'un côté 30 a clairement perdu son
audience suite à ça des plates formes
isation de facebook et twitter trump a
d'ailleurs fini par arrêter son blog par
nombre d'audiences mais dans d'autres
cas là des plates formes isation a
conduit à l'émergence de communautés
plus radicales notamment sur le forum
patriotes point win autre sujet de débat
ne semble pas évident de dire si des
plateformes alternatives et
décentralisées comme mastodonte pire
tube ou signal réduiront ou amplifieront
la désinformation mais vu l'ampleur de
la désinformation sur télégramme
whatsapp à moins de système de
modération performant sur ces
plateformes voire de régulation avec
audit externe beaucoup semblent très
préoccupée par l'augmentation de l'effet
de bulles et par des techniques de
désinformation ciblés sur de telles
plateformes certaines plateformes avec
très peu de modération sont en fait
particulièrement connu pour être très
radical comme forte chan ou beach août
le réseau social par leur a même été
banni de l'apple store et des serveurs
d'amazon pour manque de modération autre
grand sujet de contention celui du
démantèlement des gars femmes cela
réduira tilt ou amplifier at-il la
désinformation il ya un an avant le
démantèlement de l'éthique chez google
et les révélations des facebook files
j'aurais dit que cela allait clairement
amplifier la désinformation ses
plateformes ayant déjà mise en place de
nombreux outils pour combattre les
contenus conspirationnistes les contenus
qui nie le changement climatique le
cyberharcèlement le revenge porn ou
encore les vidéos de décapitation ou de
tortures les alternatives donc
généralement pas des outils de
modération capable de mesurer des
contenus surtout à l'échec gargantuesque
de dizaines de milliers d'heures de
nouvelles vidéos par heure mais vu à
quel point les gars femmes fournissent
des efforts très insuffisants pour
modérer l'information et au contraire
amplifie largement le public peut être
qu'un démantèlement partiel avec des
pressions pour licencier certaines
personnes ça serait l'occasion de
nettoyer la culture ambiante de
maximisation à font du profit dans la
direction de ces entreprises autre grand
sujet de débat dont on a déjà parlé sur
scène ce rôle l'efficacité de
l'éducation à l'école si on fait le
bilan de l'éducation aujourd'hui qui est
le fruit de décennies des fortes et de
centaines de milliards d'investissements
par an il y a de quoi être très déçu la
vaccination et le changement climatique
sont au programme scolaire mais la
défiance envers les vaccins et le manque
de connaissances des pollutions des
différentes énergies notamment par
exemple au sujet du nucléaire le bilan
de tout ça est en fait assez effrayant
pire encore le bilan de l'enseignement
des mathématiques lui me semble
complètement absolument catastrophique
seulement une faible proportion de la
population disons des 25 ans est capable
d'appliquer la règle de trois alors que
la majorité de la population semble
maintenant traumatisé des mathématiques
est ça qu on parle avec michaël youn et
ça rend le fait de parler de
mathématiques au grand public encore
plus difficile que s'il n'avait jamais
eu d'éducation mathématiques plus
inquiétant encore parmi les personnes
ayant reçu une éducation scientifique il
persiste une mes informations
importantes typiquement aux us plus les
républicains ont une grande éducation
scientifique plus une ni l'origine
humaine du changement climatique bref
plutôt que de mettre un milliard par an
de plus dans l'éducation nationale il
pourrait être plus efficace pour
combattre des informations d'investir ce
milliard de dollars dans l'amélioration
de l'environnement informationnel de
tous les français au quotidien et pas
juste ceux qui sont encore à l'école par
exemple en améliorant la qualité de la
production médiatique dans les médias
classiques ou en modifiant les
algorithmes de recommandations pour
commander davantage de contenu éducative
qui par exemple aiderait à mieux
identifier l'information fiable sur
notre sujet il ya aussi des débats sans
doute moins important sur la pertinence
de la recherche sur la détection des
fuites fake et peut-être plus
généralement sur l'identification
défectueuses en particulier me semble
personnellement plus efficace de
s'appuyer beaucoup plus sur la promotion
des contenus dont la qualité est
suffisamment certifié notant aussi le
but est d'améliorer l'environnement
informationnel que de chercher sans
cesse à combattre le flux interminable
d'informations trompeuses enfin une
dernière réflexion délicate concerne les
collaborations entre les institutions et
les influenceurs comme on l'a déjà vu il
s'agit souvent d'un exercice délicat qui
peut crédibiliser ou amplifier un
message mais qui peut aussi
décrédibilisé l'institution et
d'influenceurs sent pas y avoir de
règles simples à suivre chaque
opportunité doit sans doute être
analysée au cas par cas
[Musique]
quelle solution mesure proposeriez vous
pour lutter contre l'épidémie d'un box
il me semble urgent d'améliorer la
qualité de l'information promu à grande
échelle via les médias classiques les
livres dans les librairies et les
contenus en ligne et pour cela il faut
au préalable concevoir un système qui
permet d'estimer robustement la qualité
de l'information non seulement en termes
de fiabilité mais aussi en termes
d'importance et d'accessibilité entre
autres pour y arriver avec des collègues
nous avons co fondé la plateforme
tournesol qui vise à collecter les
jugements d'un grand nombre de
contributeurs sur la qualité de
différentes vidéos youtube selon
différents critères nous cherchons
également à certifier ses contributeurs
notamment via le nom de domaine de leur
adresse email pour éviter les faux
comptes et pour valoriser l'expertisé
des contributeurs des algorithmes
robustes sont ensuite utilisées pour
transformer les jugements des différents
contributeurs en des scores par vidéo la
conception de tels algorithme est
d'ailleurs au coeur de mon activité de
recherche nous espérons que à terme
tournesol servira de microscopes des
jugements humains pour nous permettre de
comprendre quels contenus sont reconnues
d'utilité publique par la communauté de
contributeurs et pour fournir ensuite
les solutions techniques nécessaires
pour rendre les algorithmes de
recommandations des grandes entreprises
robustement bénéfique pour la société
bon sinon c'est pas du tout reliée
directement tournesol mais je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup à apprendre du cas de
taiwan notamment dans l'effort de
valorisation des contenus vraiment au
sensuelle
[Musique]
quelles sont d'après vous les acteurs
personnes ou institutions que la
commission devrait consulter
alors j'ai mis en premier au port terre
sans frontières j'ai parlé notamment
avec un membre de reporters sans
frontières il m'a beaucoup parlé
notamment de l'importance du classement
google pour les journalistes et
l'urgence à l'audit et pour vérifier
notamment qui recommande davantage et
contenu fiable et du coup bah il dit est
très intéressé par tournesol autres
personnes à consulter ça ne vous
surprendra sans doute pas el mahdi el
mahdi professeur à l'école polytechnique
et chercheur à google et co auteur du
livre le fabuleux chantier et d'ailleurs
si vous voulez l'écouter ben je
l'interviewais à deux reprises sur ma
chaîne autre personne que je trouve très
perspicace sur ces questions mariam
tighanimine doctorante all is du cnam et
du cnrs et autres is du livre dévoilant
nous qui vient de sortir qui est un
excellent livre sur la remise en cause
paisible de nos croyances erronées bon
bien sûr le livre parle en particulier
au cou du cas du vol mais il a aussi des
réflexions qui vont bien au delà par
ailleurs notamment dans le cadre de sa
thèse marianne travail sur le rôle des
corps intermédiaires et en particulier
les journalistes sur la manière dont
l'information est diffusée autre
personne très pertinentes avec qui
discuter lui faut qu'on cofondateur de
tournesol que vous pouvez d'ailleurs
écouter sur notre podcast robot sli
beneficial en anglais même s'il ya plus
d'épisodes depuis un petit bout de temps
lui est aussi celui qui a pas mal guidé
le développement du code de tournesol
c'est en aidant partie grâce à lui si
tournesol en est là où il en est
aujourd'hui vous connaissez très
certainement christophe michel vidéaste
et de la chaîne hygiène mentale qui est
sans doute aujourd'hui le plus grand
représentant de l'esprit critique
bienveillant dans la sphère francophone
et j'ai d'ailleurs interviews et
christophe dans un podcast précédent
autres personnes très compétentes sur
ces sujets guillaume chalot ancien
employé de google créateur d'algues au
transfèrement ci est aujourd'hui expert
en iard du pôle d'expertisé de la
régulation du numérique ou pérennes en
france puis interviews et guillaume dans
un podcast précédent c'est d'ailleurs
guillaume qui m'a introduit à marcq
fadoul cofondateur de yahoo forensics et
youtube que vous avez d'ailleurs
peut-être vu dans une vidéo récente des
mes plantes d'ailleurs la solution
youtube développé par marc et ses
collègues pour mieux choisir nos
recommandations intègre tournesol
voilà telles étaient les réponses que
j'ai donné à la commission présidée par
gérald bronner j'espère bien sûr
qu'elles seront prises en compte mais
pour l'instant en tout cas je n'ai
aucune garantie et je ne me pose en
aucun cas garant des décisions qui sont
prises par la commission en fait je n'ai
pas plus de responsabilités vis-à-vis de
cette commission que la réponse que j'ai
est sonné et que je vous ai présenté
aujourd'hui